there is Sarah Jessica Parker with her
husband Matthew Broderick and SJP total
something really interesting they have a
budding fashionista at home apparently
one of my daughters is plotting to take
over
she has designs so to speak on running
as she says Mama's company Mama's
company well they make fashions her Sex
in the City character would kill for
this shoe happens to be coincidentally
called to carry only et with eras s JC
took the stage at Fast Company's
innovation festival
she says she's always bold both in
business and in her fashion choices I
would never go back in time and say that
was risky and that was and everybody
else feels very comfortable telling me
or talking about it and that's perfectly
fine Sarah Jessica's newest business
venture is a line of little black
dresses a lot of women rely upon a
little black dress most valuable player
in your closet it's the thing a lot of
us reach for always we want to know that
that's a choice for us because a black
dress just seems to suit a lot of
different moments in our lives we
totally agree and in the words of Carrie
Bradshaw just can be a really big closet